[Music]
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a tree a race of noble boys
heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these memories something
in my past is the key to all of this
you're not a Bladensburg we'll see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
I think I had a life here
what aren't you telling me
you've come a long way but you know as
strong as you think
[Music]
the slaw is just the beginning
I'm not going to fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sure the cutest thing what's your
name first things first any man here
that wants to walk away can do so
knowing they're the best of us it's
gotta be now there's no ground support
[Music]
energy sustain we're walking out with
make no mistake about it you guys need
to own the fact if we do not have the
flag on our shoulders
you cannot go back to your normal life
after tonight everything we've done for
the last 17 years nothing to show for it
you've been shot five times for your
country and you can't even afford to
send your kids to college if we'd
accomplished the things that we've
accomplished than any other profession
we set for life I'm your master the
question is do we finally get to use our
skills for our own benefit we're gonna
get Gabrielle on my team over half he's
got over 75 million dollars in cash if
you're not going forever after you make
your move we are dead we need to hunt
you cannot date they will find us
it's always a little hard and you think
it's gonna baby
we don't live like that
is this not what I signed up for a lot
of people are gonna come after you
so it goes through
you
[Music]
welcome baby Dumbo
all family here no matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
yes something very rare
you have wonder
[Music]
you have mystique
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we can soar on my elephant
wings
what's happening were they taking her
take them go back inside but Jesus mom
do something she needs us look at me
we're gonna bring your mama huh
he doesn't look like magic to me
[Music]
you're telling need you to believe
you can do it Dumbo shows
[Applause]
outside of them
fly baby
I read about you in the paper last
mostly yes I don't really know how to
though I done enough yo Billy the Kid
my father is beating my mother to death
lately with me while he'll take us with
you
how long even sheriff have two weeks
do not feel special when they start
writing about it means you're already
dead all of a sudden I'm enemy number
one there are families in this town hurt
by this man's crimes come again
[Music]
you think she could run for me that one
has two ties to I think that one of
life's partialities
now hold on one more step and it will be
your last you really think I'm watching
I know it is my lucky day wonderful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think I do you hurt one hair
on his head I'm taking my nephew with me
every single one of these peoples gonna
tell the tale right you ran they know
it's not true doesn't matter what's true
it matters the story they tell when
you're gone
[Music]
let me but you've got in your 16 I think
might be good to have a doctor look at
you sometime might be good to have
doctor with you sometime
ain't got no button cuz I was covering
you may have heard there was prison
break
it was Bonnie and Clyde governor this
has to end they committed dozens of
armed robberies and several cold-blooded
murders what do you plan to do about
Bonnie and Clyde we will capture them
rat that down and underline it twice
there's only one man who can take them
down I'll come back hey you got a room
for one more night you're packed
Oh Judas Priest Gideon
this is 1934 gangsters submachine guns
and you put Cowboys on bunny in five
Texas Rangers forgive me Father for I
have seen this is a highly coordinated
operation so much pain and suffering
roadblocks air surveillance your times
past cowboy
what the hell's the world coming to used
to be you had to have talent to get
published now all you gotta do is shoot
people she used her foot to turn him
over so he could see what was about to
happen
Patsy this has gone far enough
when I take them down what a fine idea
[Music]
who are you Phyllis I was were the bad
guys
come to the wrong place mister around
here cloud is king but
ride my be king but I'm a Texas Ranger
you little [ __ ] now I didn't see me
it could have happened at anybody but it
didn't it happened us
[Applause]
a new band is gonna be something
nobody's ever seen before
oh my god was in my pants but they look
so much better on me we gotta run away a
toothed plumber
an old man let's just play it calmer
Bansi they say we're gonna be a rock
strike
what do you think
[Music]
holy [ __ ] we want to knock people on
their asses then we've got to give him a
show I'm talking like a stadium show in
the club's the fans that die for some
anarchy so let's give it to him
[Music]
I work for Elektra Records you guys like
a record you
[Music]
[Applause]
I had managed the scorpions Bon Jovi
skid-row
kiss but I had never been through what
motley crew put me
I am sick and tired of not having any
fun everything's upside-down and
flip-floppy motley crue no strangers to
controversies Neal was charged with
vehicular manslaughter Tommy Lee and
Heather Locklear have separated it's a
degenerative bone disease nikki sixx has
overdosed I know it's like amazing but I
am leaving you nuts
[Music]
[Music]
here are we
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel no no look at you
[Music]
as to finding bodies it's chaos out
there
this house is being requisitioned by the
British government this is just your
house all of your hub now Lewis Helen
Morgan please come inside
so my what
[Music]
my daughter and I will stay out of your
way until we moved to the camp what if
we let them stay warm you mean live with
them I may not be an outward show of
hatred but is there below the surface
during the war did you ever hope for a
German victory did the bombing affect
the health of you and your family it
affected the health of my wife she died
in the firestorm I'm so sorry you didn't
tell me what I was walking into this
isn't how it was supposed to be none of
us is how it is supposed to be please
don't go I have a job to do
[Music]
we're going to spy on a girl the least
you could do is pay a compliment yes of
course
[Music]
something's changed be careful that's
when they don't like us
but before that I could be happy but
come this is what you wanted
new beginnings
[Music]